EDEN SHOCHAT: So I'll
start off with a bit
of a personal story
about GeekCon.
So it's a conference, three days
and you build useless stuff.
But that's the most basic
thing about GeekCon.
And some three years
ago, which means my son
was four years old.
He came in for the
closing session.
And in the closing
session we had laser show.
I actually created
the laser show
by taking and dismantling
a speaker and putting,
instead of the
membrane I put a glove.
And on top of the
glove I put a mirror,
and that mirror would fluctuate
as the sound came out.
And that turned
into a laser show.
And to date, every time I
mention the word GeekCon,
my son Ofek basically
admirers me.
That's the one thing that
he remembers three years,
since he was a four-year-old
which, generally, you don't
remember anything from when
you were a four-year-old.
Right?
So if I take a step back, my
job-- I'm a venture capitalist.
In a way, it's the
best job in the world.
I get to give people money in
order to pursue their dreams.
Right?
And still, the most creative
people from all of these, I
wait for one thing every year.
And that one thing is
this Geek's conference
I'll talk about today.
And I'll talk about
three different things.
I'll talk about, the
first one, is, what is it?
That's the first thing.
The second thing is, why do
we still do it after 10 years?
And the third thing is my
hope that people sitting here
will create one yourself.
And how can you do it?
So how do we run GeekCon
and how do we make it work?
So the first way to
learn about GeekCon
is through something-- it's
a project that never existed.
The person doing it
never intended to do it.
The guy doing it is now
an MIT Media Lab rat.
He came in to do something
completely different and then
he saw a bunch of equipment
and what you don't hear--
and we've tried to debug it--
is that he was playing popcorn
on something that just didn't
exist three days before.
And this is not the kind of
project that GeekCon but it
just happened by itself.
So if I look at this.
This is a post from Facebook
just from yesterday,
people trying to think what
kind of project will they do.
So this is a guy called
[INAUDIBLE], and he's thinking,
do I do a 3D sand
castle printer?
So he's saying, I don't
want to build castles
with my kids every day so let's
do a 3D printer that does that.
Remember, three days.
That's the whole conference.
This is what he wants to do.
Option number two is to
have no fire fireworks.
Right?
So he would do 3D
printing and fire off.
And he's asking
for people to vote.
And obviously, the third option,
that's kind of boring, right?
Dominoes robot.
But it's the kind
of work that people
do before they go into GeekCon.
We are three months
before the conference,
and these are some of the
top suggestions that people
are offering right
now for GeekCon.
So the first one is
a two meter diameter
ball that has a camera
on it that is stabilized
and it goes out
and badges people.
Useless, right?
But that's exactly
the kind of projects
that we're looking for in
building for those three days.
Other projects, physical
Digger-- so having robots
run around try to
replicate what Digger was.
Anyone actually played Digger?
Anyone is old enough
to play Digger?
Nice.
So why not do it with robots.
Right?
That's the kind of spirit that
we have in people doing that.
So a few projects.
The first one, how
do you flower plants?
How do you water plants?
You go ahead and
just water them.
But that's not what
GeekCon people do.
What they do is build a
quad copter as a platform,
have water to it, image
recognition, so it finds
the plants below it,
and when it finds,
it actually sends
water their way.
This is the kind of projects
that people are doing.
This is a urinal.
It's a repeat pattern in GeekCon
where people actually control,
in this case, a computer game.
You can imagine how.
Right?
And again, useless projects.
And I'll talk a lot about that.
Third thing is, this is a
meta builder of race cars.
And what I mean by metabuilder,
it builds race cars
by building something that
builds race cars-- remote
controlled-- with vegetables.
So it actually builds these
kind of race cars by itself.
You give it a
potato it will build
a potato based race car driver.
You give it a tomato
it will build this way.
And the bonus points,
it will actually
drive power with a vegetable.
That's actually
from two years ago.
So smart, crazy
stupid, who does that?
That's Tesla that would
be the ideal GeekCon
participant, right?
And at the day it's one person,
finding that one person,
that's crazy enough in
order to build something
that will make a difference.
In this case, fun.
Right?
But will make a difference.
These are the change makers
that we're looking for.
So process wise,
how this whole thing
comes to bear is
thinking, what if we
find 200 people like that?
200 people who are smart crazy
in order to build something.
So step number one,
find those people.
We're based out of Israel.
GeekCon is now a
worldwide conference.
So it used to be just a bunch
of Israelis playing around
for three days.
Now, people from India,
Singapore, Germany, Great
Britain, US they're all
coming in order to build that.
So now it became a very
big international event.
What it was not just
a few years back.
Take technology lovers and
put them in a single place
in order to create
useless stuff.
And why is that important?
Why is useless important?
Because people are much more
creative when they do that.
When you tell them
you will not be
judged according to what you do
but you will be judged as how
cool that is, how does it defy
kind of technology barrier
and go ahead and
build something.
So this is what GeekCon
has become, right?
You take like-minded
people and you tell them
they will not be judged.
What do you think this is?
It's people fighting on
top of rubber platforms
that direct them to the
people next to them.
So like go karts.
Do you remember the game?
But this is the Geek
version of go karts.
You take and you basically tell
people, yeah, you can build it
and you'll be appreciated
with only one rule.
So never mind what
your pedigree is.
Doesn't matter if you
were CTO of somewhere,
doesn't matter whether
you have done an exit.
The only thing we
care about is that you
have to have a project.
So the whole thing
starts now, about,
for 2014 where we send out
a request for proposals.
So in the proposals
we basically say,
the only thing that
we'll check is do we
believe that you can actually
do it and is the project crazy.
And applications wise, there are
about 400 people, 400 groups,
different groups, that
send in applications.
And we can only except
about 40 of them.
So you can imagine
the level of extreme
that people go to when
they talk about projects.
The rolling ball, one example.
But the more interesting
one is just two years ago
someone was playing
orchestra with puppets
by controlling it with
a Microsoft Connect.
So these are the
kind of projects.
And it's really
beautiful, right?
It's absolutely useless
but it's beautiful
because you're actually
controlling a bunch of puppets.
I love it.
So no project, no entry rule.
Actually there
there's a second rule.
This is the useless projects.
And really a third rule, because
the third most expensive part
of GeekCon is insurance.
Right?
So the first is, we
provide accommodations--
it's three days--
that's accommodations.
The second thing is coffee
throughout the 72 hours.
And the third is insurance.
And can you guess why?
The kind of projects.
So three years ago we fired
off a missile by mistake.
And how do you
file off a missile
by mistake is if you
strap it to a surf board
and that surfboard tilts then
you'll get a missile launch.
And that about doubled our
insurance rates for the year
after that.
So accepting differences
of the different people
and promote to the extreme.
So in this case, can you
imagine what this is?
Trampoline.
Right?
But what can you do with a
trampoline that is interesting?
If you jump, your silhouette
becomes your login password.
So if you want to log
into your computer
again you need to jump
exactly that same way.
Now, the interesting
part with that
is that it's actually
fairly deep tech.
In order to do this, you need
to have image recognition that
takes and hashes the
value of what is the jump
and what kind of
posture this person had.
And then it actually
evaluates next time
whether these are the same.
So it's a login.
It's well before the login
announcements by Google today.
I think this is the next gen.
So the guys behind it went
ahead and did gesture matching.
It's one of the bigger
companies in Israel,
one of the top leaders
in gesture matching.
And it came from
a useless project.
It all started with that.
We don't have enough
women participants.
We're at about 15% and
we're constantly increasing,
but this project was led by
Ifat, if I remember her name.
And the basic project was, how
about we do a Breathalyzer.
Breathalyzer, the
reason to do it
is in order not to
have too much alcohol.
But this is GeekCon
so it checked
whether you have enough
alcohol in your blood.
And if not, it poured you drink.
So highly successful, was one
of the more visited projects
throughout the period.
You want cat pictures, right?
But it's not fun if
the cat isn't scared.
So these guys actually
built image recognition,
finds a cat walks in,
make sure it's scares them
and if so it takes
an immediate picture.
Not very animal friendly.
By the way, if you have
questions or comments
or questions, don't make
it an American session.
You can just fire off as you go.
This project, again,
three days, and it
was a roller coaster
for cell phones.
So what do you do before?
You'd record you
shouting and then
it used the
accelerometer in order
to understand whether the
phone should be scared.
And if it should be scared,
it used your own voice
in order to scream.
So the cell phone was
the suffering part
but you were actually
doing the ride.
And they built the
roller coaster itself,
the whole thing, in
the same location
at that same three days period.
Superman simulator.
So this is a terrain engine, a
military grade terrain engine
3D simulator that you controlled
by being suspended in mid air.
And you had a
controller on your hand
so you could
actually fly through.
And the feeling was
really like a Superman.
Mostly useless.
Can you imagine what this is?
So we don't have
insurance for sea
so this was actually
objectionable
as far as our insurance goes.
But they just build
it in order to prove
that you don't need to have
a technology at all in order
to build a useless project.
This is a wheel, right?
The way it's structured
within GeekCon,
it's a large space
because we want
people to be really
close to one another.
And the things that
happen because of that
is, for example, you need
a capacitator, right?
You're a maker, you're a
hardware, but you didn't have,
you didn't bring
something from home.
So one event that
actually happened,
2:00 AM, someone says, who
has a 20 kilo-ohm capacitor?
Someone immediately
raised and they got.
So that's why we
want the small space.
And that generates a
lot of interactions
between the different people.
But on the porch you actually
see the Mediterranean here
and this is where the more,
the riskier projects happen.
On this side.
Like robots that run around.
Right?
So that's where
we have them now.
And the whole thing starts by
people joining in Thursday.
So it used to be Thursday
night, it now is Thursday noon.
And they pitch their projects.
So you say, hey, I want
to build this drawer
and the drawer
will open and close
if you push down towards it.
So you pitch.
And many teams actually
dismantle that point and say,
hey, your project
is so much cooler
than mine so I'll just
move ahead and do that.
That's Thursday,
that's what's going on.
And by Saturday we're
actually doing demos.
What happens in between
is things like that.
This is a user generated dinner.
What happens in the user
generated dinner by geeks?
A flamethrower, 10
meter flamethrower,
is used in order to
create creme brulee.
So it's user generated.
They do whatever.
A quad copter goes
up above the barbecue
in order to supply the
air supply because you
do want to have
a great barbecue.
So last year was
biological cooking.
So anything that geeks do
then translates into food
and it ends with trying to
convince our families that they
gave up on us for three
days for a good reason.
So people from either the
sponsors or luminaries
or people from industry
and definitely the families
try and understand
what is that we do.
And that ends Saturday 3:00 PM.
So we start Thursday
2:00 PM to Saturday 3:00
PM and all projects must be
completed within this time
period.
Some people cheat by doing
some preparation in advance,
but everything is
done in three days.
They are building by designers,
makers, hardware engineers,
software engineers,
everything is built on site
in order to create that.
And the whole thing
has been running
now-- it's the 10th year.
And it's entirely
volunteer based event.
So no one is paid in order
to do this weird thing.
So this is the initial
team that started it.
And this year we actually
have 30 volunteers.
So this year is
GeekCon X. We wanted
to make it the biggest, baddest,
greatest projects of all
the time and so we
have a very big team.
And how you do-- oh, by numbers.
I didn't remember
having this slide.
So 180 people.
This year is actually
going to be 200.
And the way we managed
to do that is people
actually volunteered
to come in in tents
and sleep in tents
in order to be
able to increase the
amount of people.
52, it's now going
to be 72 hours.
40 useless projects.
We really like beer
so there's always
a local brewery
that supplies us.
But the interesting-- and we
have pretty much all the time
coffee.
But the interesting thing is
what's our goal in doing this.
And the goal that we have
is 66% failure rates.
So last year we failed because
we had a 50% success rate.
And why do-- why do
you go for the 66%?
The whole idea of GeekCon, much
like other venues like that,
is building the infrastructure,
building the framework that
makes people so
much more creative.
Right?
And the way to make
them more creative
is by telling them
we want you to fail.
So there has been
projects like firing
down mosquitoes with lasers.
And that half worked because
they mostly hit people.
But that-- so is that success,
is that failure, we don't know.
But it's pretty cool.
So we really want to fail.
And some people think
that we're less crazy
than we think that we are.
So Google has been
helping us in many ways.
But General Motors,
who would expect
General Motors to
sponsor a bunch of geeks
that try to useless stuff?
Face.com, a company I founded,
was actually born there.
So that's one great impact.
So we got to know
each other, people
get to know between teams.
But that's a side effect.
Interesting other
side effects is
conferences that get
built because of that.
And in my mind, that's
my goal for this session.
So GeekCon, again,
insurance we can't
bring people that
are younger than 18.
So we are pressured by
some of the participants
in order to create
GeekCon for kids.
One day events and those kids
build the most crazy stuff.
Much more-- they are much
less burdened with limitations
than the parent.
So the kid thinks of the
idea and you suddenly
see everyone building into it.
Which is awesome.
TentTech, DrinkCon.
DrinkCon is going to happen
for the first time this year.
It's GeekCon for alcohol side.
Think of sauna based on alcohol.
Going to be interesting.
We'll see.
TentTech is taking
clean tech and doing
that in the same
spirit of GeekCon.
So in the desert, two
days, build things.
But built in that space.
Right?
It's not things that
you bring in advance.
Well, OK.
Amdocs, a company
that was doing this.
The Israel Defense
Forces has actually
copied off the
GeekCon model and they
have an event internal
for the intelligence corp
and for Air Force that
they are doing in order
to build more creative things.
And so we have done
that with Microsoft.
So how can you do this?
It's pretty easy.
It's a lot of work
but it's pretty easy.
So GeekCon, in order to
have it up and running,
there was a spreadsheet.
What a surprise, everything
is a spreadsheet, right?
So first off, when
we started planning
for GeekCon X-- this is
this year-- we said, OK,
what do we want to do?
What are the principles
that we have?
We want bigger organizer
team, have it longer,
do two pre-cons meaning
conferences that
happened before in order
to help people team up
and build bigger projects.
In order for them to
understand 3D printing,
in order for them
to do Oculus Rift.
There's actually a project,
a submarine controlled Oculus
Rift control
submarine this year.
And many ways, that's because
of those pre-con structures.
So these are the principles.
This is what we wanted to do.
Bring in more women, get
internet to work finally,
tenth year, we've never been
able to do good internet
infrastructures.
So these are the principles.
Then we went off and said,
OK, so these are the teams
that we need.
There are 30 teams that are
charged with tear down, set
up, projects, website,
pretty much anything that
needs to happen in order
to get things going.
And you then find owners
for each of those.
These are the volunteers
that now there
are 30 of them instead of
the four that we are usually.
And then the how to.
The file is actually
called How To.
And these are all the to do's.
And surprisingly, the amount
of to do's is very, very deep
before the event.
And then the event
itself runs itself.
In many ways.
So 150 things that
need to happen.
All the must items,
if they don't happen,
there will be no GeekCon.
All the high items,
if they don't happen,
it will be a OK GeekCon.
Medium, if you do the medium,
it will be an awesome GeekCon.
And low, you never do.
In startups, generally,
there is must,
muster and mustest
priority level.
And the same with GeekCon.
And this is what's going on
in the event itself, right?
So very short.
If you look before it's about
70 items, but during the event
it's basically, OK, let's
get the teams going,
give them rooms, make sure
they have a refrigerator
for the user generated
dinner, and the rest
will happen by itself.
So the organizer team, most of
the stuff that we do is ahead.
Just making sure the best
projects will be selected,
that there will be
the infrastructure,
there will be a group
buy in case people
need to buy many arduinos.
But otherwise it's running
pretty much by itself.
If you want to do a GeekCon
yourself, best way to do that
is to experience
GeekCon by coming.
Right?
So 18th to 20th of September.
This is what's
going on in Israel.
We already have a lot of
pressure in doing it in the US.
Philadelphia
volunteered to do it.
But basically anyone that
is interested in doing it,
it's a spreadsheet away
and talking with us.
Thank you.
Questions.
Who's volunteering to do it?
That's in California?
Y Combinator.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
EDEN SHOCHAT: Awesome.
So we have California going.
Questions about the
how's it going projects?
What's what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
EDEN SHOCHAT: So how does
it start, you're asking?
So great example is
the Space IL guys
that will launch to
the moon in late 2015.
Pretty much the same.
Most of the projects
we see, people
sitting in a bar, either
ex-participants or they've
heard of it.
They start scribbling
things down,
they write the application.
We usually try to help them
improve on the application.
But that's a soul.
All the soul of the project
is by the project owners.
Our job as organizers
is to have an organized
chaos, to give them the stage,
give them the infrastructure,
help them meet the right
people, like minded people,
and make sure nobody feels
that they are judged.
The number one
impact is make sure
that everyone thinks that
the crazier the better
and the more fun that's awesome.
And people are generally
always thinking, oh,
does it have a business model
or what will be the next step?
And once they get rid of that
they build awesome projects.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
EDEN SHOCHAT: Oh,
how it started?
We were at some other
conference and we said,
we are not willing
to wait a year
before we see each other again.
And that conference
was similar to Foo Camp
which was very
much about talking.
And we said, fuck it, we want
to do things, and so we did.
So first GeekCon
was with a budget
of 8,000 shekels
which is about $2,000.
And it was done
overnight and 80 people.
And really worked
great so we decided,
hey, let's do it
next year as well.
So that's pretty simple.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
EDEN SHOCHAT: No.
So great question.
Is it always the
same people coming?
So the overhead in creating
a project is so big,
and you know that
no project no entry,
we take it very seriously.
So you know that if you
come just to hang out
you will most likely not
be invited the year after.
So that's a pretty
good leverage there.
So generally what happens is
we have about a third repeat
from last year.
It's now about
1,000 people strong
that went through the
event in multiple years.
So about a third are the
same, 2/3 are coming out.
And a lot of the work
that we do-- and look
at the responsibilities.
So new recruits.
That's one of the
top responsibilities
and one of the
largest teams if you
see because we want to bring
in new blood all the time.
And it's important for us that
people have the fun in making.
And that's why we actually make
sure that we have designer.
We go to most design schools.
We go to most engineering
schools, and we just pitch.
Most of us have a day job,
and it's still something
that we constantly do.
Cool.
Thank you.